le tribunal de police d'annecy a relaxé
en journalistes poursuivis pour s'être
introduit en septembre sur le tarmac de
l'aéroport
dan s'il devait y couvrir une
manifestation menée par des militants
écologistes
dans son jugement le tribunal a
distingué le cas de gérard fumex de
celui des militants du million du
mouvement écologiste extinction
rébellion la juge a motivé sa décision
au titre de la liberté d'information est
reconnu que gérard fumex exercer son
métier de journaliste les militants ont
manifesté sur le tarmac contre le
renouvellement du bail de l'aéroport
situé à mettet et propriété du conseil
départemental de la haute savoie
un d'entre eux a été condamné à une
amende de 200 euros avec sursis plus aux
autres été appelé à la barre le même
jour c'est un l'ouverture d'un rapport
de force avec la justice en fait parce
que cette action qu'on a mené sur le
tarmac de l'aéroport a ici
pour moi elle est tout à fait légitime
au vu de la crise écologique et du déni
de démocratie que constitue le
renouvellement du bail avec avec cette
fois-ci vinci est pour moi le fait que
les activistes qui était sur le tarmac
soit condamné c'est une décision qui
légitime
j'espère que sur site ont droit comme
pour m'appelle il va tomber à un moment
donné et j'aimerais bien que ce soit
dans nos forêts le pima et que l'on
revienne à des choses
plus satisfaisante parce que notre
combat en fait c'est ça donc le sursis
oui tout à fait content avec ça mais
c'est pas suffisant
l'ensemble le travail des journalistes
et doit être garanti et il est aussi
garantie par la justice mais c'est vrai
que aujourd'hui il y a d'autres
journalistes qui sont aujourd'hui qui
sont dans la même situation sur le plan
de notre pays qui attendent un jugement
qui va être donc on espère justement que
ne serait-ce que ce jugement ici sur
annecy puisse être une jurisprudence
pour pouvoir permettre à l'ensemble des
journalistes qui font leur boulot de
pouvoir être sauvée
qui doit être protégé de l'heure pour
leur travail aux côtes